be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so we're picking up with Batman
Superman number two which god I've been
dying for this comic to come out because
like the first one was so good it was
due to his amazing I was like what a way
to intro it like what a way to bring
this in like this Shazam whoo last now
here's the cool thing and I think this
is actually gonna prove to be one of the
most important parts of this particular
story arc that that Joshua Williamson is
writing initially you pick up with
Commissioner Gordon right outside of
Gotham City in the Gotham City Police
Department armory so while it is in the
GCPD armory it isn't usually normal for
him to like kind of sneak off and meet
with somebody outside the city for a
particular purpose right in the fact
that it is the armory means that of
course it's police property meaning
Commissioner Gordon could go in there
and basically dismiss everybody
temporarily or find a place to meet and
secret and basically talk to this person
who really appears to be Catwoman more
so than anything else but he basically
talks about the various forms of
evidence and all the poisons that all
the things that the various villains
from Gotham City used that is all
basically locked down by Wayne tech
security right so this seems to indicate
that he's talking about the Batcave or
someplace basically controlled by Bruce
Wayne we could argue like Arkham Asylum
but it would make sense for for
Commissioner Gordon to be able to just
go into Arkham but there is also a lot
of red tape right I mean Commissioner
Gordon isn't really like the warden of
Arkham so he couldn't just walk in there
and take what he wants he would need a
warrant in order to be able to access
that information
it looks like he's talking to Catwoman
because he's basically saying like not
even Commissioner Gordon has access to
these things it's impossible to get past
except for this one particular person
and the reason why I say Catwoman is
because she's like the greatest thief in
all of Gotham City right and I would
probably say probably the world I mean I
don't think the DC is really broken down
the level of thieves in terms of how
they compare to everybody else but
nonetheless at this point it transitions
to the actual fight between Shazam
Superman and Batman and this I think is
really what you guys came to see the
fight between Shazam Batman is Superman
now this is the reason why this works so
well is because on the surface if you're
not really knowledgeable about like the
weaknesses of Superman
on the surface you would look at this
and just kind of see it boil down to a
fight between a Superman esque character
and Superman but it's far more
interesting than that because remember
Superman has a weakness to magic and
that's one of the things that's one of
the the I guess the upper hands this
Shazam always sort of had on him now
she's not a straight-up magic wielder
like you know like like cetana or
somebody like that but magic is invoked
in the powers that he uses and so it's
kind of cool to see Joshua Williamson
sort of tug on that little string and
then have
face off against Supes and so with
Batman being part of the fray is it sort
of funny here because it's just sort of
like Batman just a guy at a Halloween
costume right like Shazam who laughs it
doesn't really take him seriously and
indeed there's no reason for him to and
so with that being said like you
basically end up having like the the
question of Batman of where's this thing
being kept of course he's essentially on
the hunt for something and it's a cool
scenario because when is it happening as
Superman goes he uses heat vision on
Shazam and the Shazam turns back into
Billy Batson and this is genius here
this is absolutely genius here's a
reason why Shazam I always sort of saw
depicted as a young naive kid who was an
answer to the question what if a
teenager had the powers of Superman
that's really how I always saw him and
for the most part that's really what he
was like what if you woke up one day and
you had all of Superman's powers but you
had them on command I want to be
Superman now and you basically got all
those powers that that that the Man of
Steel has what would you do with that I
never saw him as the sharpest tool in
the shed I never saw him as is very good
at like trickery and deception or
anything like that and mostly because of
the fact of the way he's been written
over the years is it really exactly like
Superman it's more so that he has other
people who were smarter than him to
basically kind of help him in Adium
right so you got like the wizard Shazam
who can go to for guidance in more
recent years you have the Shazam family
he even learns lessons from my Black
Adam who's exceedingly old and has a lot
of like battle-hardened wisdom to sort
of in part on Shazam albeit by beating
the crap Adam so the fact remains that
there are a lot of teachers in the world
of Billy Batson and so I never really
saw him as a kid that doesn't really
that there needs to learn more than how
to like defeat this particular foe or to
use his brain in some smaller fashion
what he does here is genius because he
tricks the heck out of Superman he's
just like Jude Superman I'm sorry man I
don't know what's going on I get these
weird visions and nightmares and things
like that you got to find a way to help
me and it's just like messing around got
Superman to lower his guard and then
turns back into Bill it turns it back
into Shazam again right like this is
genius and this is one of the coolest
things about bringing in characters from
the dark multiverse is it gives us
iterations of the characters that we
don't normally see that while Billy
Batson is by no means an idiot he's
certainly not like super good at like
tricking people and and using like
espionage and subterfuge to get what it
is that he wants but doing that here is
really really really smart like it's
pretty awesome and so what he ends up
doing it's basically sort of kind of
revealing to Superman a bit of his
intention now in reality it should be
with a grain of salt and the reason why
I say that is because what he does is
basically saying that like hey you know
you always considered my existence to be
a joke you guys laugh at me and you guys
talk about me behind my back different
things like that basically like you
never really took me seriously you had
me on the team because I'm powerful but
not really because I matter and the
reality is that this is not Billy Batson
from the main main DC Universe
this is Billy Batson for the dark
multiverse and so what he's basically
doing is bringing all those ideologies
from the dark multiverse into the main
DC universe and then basically putting
them onto Superman right like projecting
them onto Superman and saying like how
you guys existed in my universe is how
you guys exist here which is not
necessarily true but what it does do is
allow him to maintain this fantasy of
believing what he wants to believe and
so it's a really cool concept it's a
really cool idea it's a great
reflections of people in the modern day
and so of course then you have that man
who just comes flying in with like the
Batman who laughs batwing because
remember when the Batman who laughs came
over from the dark multiverse the first
thing was being part of Dark Knight's
metal but following the defeat of
Barbados then it turned into well how
can I basically bring down this earth
and turn it into like a dark multiverse
version of itself and so it wasn't
really enough to say hey like we're
gonna start injecting people with toxins
he basically had to have systems in
place they could make him comfortable to
Batman and with Batman having all these
gadgets and things like that the Batman
who lost had to have his own version of
those and so that's why you saw the
Batman who lives having things like like
his own batwing and and so on and so
forth it was a way to just kind of build
as his presence up and that to allowing
himself to become a legitimate danger to
Bruce Wayne because at the end of the
day why would Bruce Wayne be worried
about himself running around on earth
who doesn't have a bat wing or Batmobile
or a bat boat or a bat credit card like
why would he have to worry about that
guy he's just like okay so like I'll
just track him down and then shoot him
in the face when he's like running away
from me and that would basically be it
but it's kind of a cool thing because
what Batman does is basically roll up on
Shazam and then in turn like stab him
right now what it does is it allows show
Sam to essentially like incapacitate
Batman to send him flying down to the
ground while he's unconscious and force
Superman into a choice do you want to
defeat me or do you want to save Batman
and now here's kind of a funny thing and
in reality I would have to I would have
defeated Shazam like I want to know what
would you guys have done would you guys
have defeated Shazam or would you have
saved Batman like I'm kind of curious
it's like a video game choice right like
what was it uh Arkham City we're like
you're Catwoman and you have to choose
between like taking the money and
leaving or like saving Batman I'd
livestream that at one point and all you
guys like a bunch of you guys were
watching and I was like what should I do
you guys were like let Batman
you guys are heartless you're terrible
people terrible people is what you are
but uh but but nonetheless it's really
cool here because I would have defeated
Sam and the reason why is because Batman
you know Bruce Wayne is very very
capable that's true and really like Dick
Grayson and and in Tim Drake and Damian
Wayne and Jason Todd if you chose to and
even back row like they're not really a
battle right they're not a perfect
stand-in but hey they're good enough so
I would have been like all right you
know hey sorry Batman it's been real
honest been good but it ain't been real
good cuz you're kind of a dick
so like I'm gonna defeat his am Shazam's
gotta go and then like just go to Dick
Grayson and say man it was it was
terrible man like it was awful you know
it's you know it was a tough choice to
make man but like you won't be Batman
though like this basically how it would
go that's basically how that whole
situation would go down and it is kind
of funny because in turn when Batman
wakes up in the fortress of solitude he
actually starts chastising Superman and
just being like why didn't you stop
Shazam why didn't you let me die and
indeed it would have been the smarter
move to make now of course Superman ends
up doing the Superman thing worse like
when I looked into his eyes and I saw
that it's really Billy Batson he's just
struggling with a few things and it's
like look we're not talking about drug
addiction right like we're not talking
about you know Shazam you know that the
Billy batts he got his heart broken by
some girl he met in like the ninth grade
and and like he'd and he was never in
love before and he couldn't get over it
and he was just struggling forever and
he decided the best way to do it was
become some angsty teenager who's also
an evil version of Superman more or less
but that's not what we're talking about
like we're talking about a legitimately
evil superhero out there who's who would
further the plan of the Batman who lost
and turning the entirety of the world
upside down
so it's it's kind of crazy because in
doing this and it's sort of taunting of
Superman what Shazam basically revealed
to him is that the Batman who laughs is
working with basically dark multiverse
versions of themselves right so like the
Superman who laughs and the Wonder Woman
who laughs and the Aquaman who laughs at
different things like that what it does
is it provides them with an N and this
is kind of the benefit of Superman and
it's why he did what he did right
because it's kind of like okay look we
could defeat Shazam who lasts but at the
end of the day we're treating a symptom
we're not treating the cause we need to
actually treat the cause right so let
the small fish go to catch the big fish
that's the cool thing that goes on here
and so we were basically he sits down
and analyzes these batarangs that were
used by the Batman who last and each one
is basically encoded to the particular
DNA sequence of each member of the
Justice League and designed to infect
them in a
way that will basically allow complete
and total control right so Superman
being a being the weak to kryptonite the
battery was laced with some form of
kryptonite most likely in order to
basically pierce the body of Superman
and then in turn infect him is the
question is where do we go from here and
that's when Batman and Superman formed
this plan what they end up doing is
basically traveling out and the Oh
Batman says like no one can know what
we're doing here this has to say secret
now this is really the question that I
had is without with a scenario like this
like a Shazam who lasts running around
out there you know how does it Justice
League not get involved and is basically
Batman telling Superman like no one can
know what we're doing this has to be a
secret mission between the two of us no
one can be aware of what's going on and
then he asked the question are you truly
ready for this and the response of
Superman is one I always knew that you
had the Batman who laughs being held
underneath the Hall of Justice because
I'm a journalist you know now in reality
it could have also been like I just use
x-ray vision because I was bored one day
and I wanted to see if anything need to
be cleaned and then I just saw that the
Batman who last is under there and I was
like what in the heck is going on like I
mean you know it that would be kind of
cool it would've been pretty interesting
too but but nonetheless Superman figured
it out very very fast and he basically
says it's the only real option that we
have and so this is what's really cool
here is because suddenly you switch over
to the Batman who lasts and when that
happens like in comes Superman as the
Superman who lost and the Batman who
lost greets him as an old friend which
is crazy because here's the question I
have is this actually the Superman like
like Superman who's fine and for taining
to be the Batman who lasts or is it
Superman who is who is like the Superman
who lasts right like is that really
what's going on I imagine it's probably
him faking it but it'd be awesome if it
wasn't this entire time it was actually
the Superman who laughs who was
pretending and like Billy Batson
transforming into the normal version of
himself is Joshua Williamson's Way of
telling us that that would be awesome
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come let's explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoy
this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later purse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]